deux amis folles bien mytho il doit
avoir un verre comme ça et l'autre il
lui dit alors tu as fait quoi hier et du
bon rien si si enfin j'étais un moment
j'étais chez moi j'ai voulu une
entrecôte et donc j'ai appelé le riche
j'aurais dit les gars c'est David
préparer moi la chambre 505 la plus
belle je veux une entrecôte je suis
menti il arrive je commence à manger un
peu et bon il y avait pas de moutarde
donc je leur ai demandé la moutarde mais
j'ai pas la moutarde comme j'aime de
Dijon donc j'ai la paix de Bourget et je
leur ai dit avancer le jet j'arrive je
vais chercher la moutarde et bref bon et
toi qu'est-ce que tu as fait non moi
j'étais en boîte hier
j'ai posé une bouteille la plus belle
bouteille et là à côté de moi il y a à
Kim Kardashian qui a posé une bouteille
à côté de moi et tout et je vois quand
même comment ça me chauffer comme ça
elle veut danser on commence à chauffer
pas et à l'oreille comment ça me dit
elle croit que je crois pas en anglais
elle me dit i want sex with you
[Musique]
on sait elle me dit never now never je
l'ai pris ramener chez moi
kim Kardashian
bref on s'éclate on se met sur le lit on
fume une clope comme ça elle reçoit un
FaceTime qui reçoit le FaceTime de
comment faire
[Rires]
rihanna est bien chez moi les de Rihanna
kim Kardashian
c'est quoi cette soirée fous pourquoi tu
m'as pas appelé déjà appelé chez toi
j'ai ta mère elle m'a répondu mais tu es
à Dijon frère
[Applaudissements]
elle est magnifique elle est magnifique
c'est un couple ça fait
50 ans ils sont mariés a compris le truc
ils sont mariés depuis 50 ans et un
moment donné il y a le mari qui décède
et 15 jours après la femme elle décède
aussi et là ils arrivent au paradis et
la femme elle voit son mari au paradis
elle court elle dit mon amour tu as vu
je t'ai rejoins lui dit écoute Mireille
ah le prêtre il a dit jusqu'à que la
mort nous sépare
Frédéric alors c'est une blonde balade
dans la rue et elle trouve un pingouin
et tu es tout seul mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais là
elle prend le pingouin il est un peu
lourd elle croise un flic elle dit ouais
monsieur lajean que comment qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire de ce pingouin
je sais pas moi je fais la circulation
bah emmener le haut
deux jours après il la recroise et puis
avec le pingouin et tout s'entendent
bien puis je fais mais comment ça se
fait que vous avez vous êtes encore avec
les pingouins elle dit bah je sais pas
vous m'avez dit de l'emmener au zoo
maintenant ce soir on va au cinéma
[Applaudissements]
ils arrivent ils sont dans le zoo et
tout d'un coup il passe devant la cage
de laurent-outan au dos argenté et alors
Laurentin voilà la femme il fait
le mari fait tu as vu tu as regardé tu
as regardé mais non
c'est un peu elle avance près de la
grille
[Rires]
un peu ton chemisier ouvre un peu ton
chemisier mais ça va pas ou quoi il y a
personne n'ouvre un peu ton jeu elle
ouvre un peu le chemisier
c'est extraordinaire je te jure c'est
formidable regarde non mais ouvre
complètement le truc
elle ouvre le chemisier
relève ta jupe
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est compliqué dis oui mais
je peux pas t'engager bref il parle le
mec un mois après il se recroise ça va
Charlie qu'est-ce que tu deviens
trouver du travail
téléphone mais tu fais quoi dans le
téléphone c'est moi qui fait le pipi
c'est une femme elle rentre elle rentre
dans la chambre
avec un berger allemand
son mari qui est dans le lit elle fait
titre en compte tu te rends compte je
suis obligé de vivre avec cette anne tu
te rends compte je suis obligé de dire
c'est pas à toi que je parle
[Applaudissements]